أن ابتكار Bo في تاريخ تشاي واحد
هو الطعام والطعام هو التاريخ ،
فالمطعم ذو الثلاث نجوم ميشلان يحتوي على جميع
أطباقه المستوحاة من الأحداث أو الأشخاص في
التاريخ.
الحمض النووي الخاص بي هو إبداع إبداعي ،
لكن إبداعًا عمليًا بدأته في
وقت متأخر جدًا من العمر أكثر من 40 ألفين يستخدم
لدفع حدود الإبداع في
المطبخ الذي عمل مع فنان
لإنشاء هذه اللوحة الجدارية الرائعة التي تصور
اللحظات المحورية في تاريخ هونغ كونغ
إنها نسختي  من التاريخ في هونغ
كونغ ، لذلك هناك الكثير من العناصر
التي عميقة جدًا في ذاكرتي
عام 1986 كان إعلان
المقبض ولكنه في الواقع جزء واحد
في كل شيء ، دعنا نصف كيف
ترى هذا المكان الذي أود قوله  إنه
مجرد الاستمرار والاستمرار ، دعنا نذهب إلى
المطبخ هذا يسمى قصيدة
التنين ويمكنك أن ترى من هذه اللوحة
كلها تنين مثل كل الأطباق
لقد ابتكر قصة وتاريخًا
وراء هذا ، وهو يشيد ببدلة المسار
الأسطوري Bruce Lee في فيلم Game of Death الأخير ،
لاحظت اللون
الأصفر وسأضع هذا الخط من
الثوم الأسود والفاصوليا السوداء جيدًا وآمل أن يكون
هناك أكثر من مجرد  واحدة على اللوحة
الآن تريد الحصول على
دقيقة واحدة تريدها ، إنها
أرض فرصة في هونغ كونغ ، لذا
يمكنك دائمًا شراء واحدة ثانية ، لا أعرف
ما تفعله.
تحمل
تكلفة أخرى لقد رأيت أنه
يرى القليل من نفسه في الطريقة التي يرى بها سكان هونغ كونغ
أنفسهم ،
نحن ناجون تقول إننا نتكيف حتى
تعلم أننا قد تغيرنا مثل الفراشة ،
لقد غيرنا الكلمة الواحدة التي
ستستخدمها  وصف هونغ كونغ سيكون
لوصف محول DN الذي أعتقد أنه قابل للتكيف ،
أود أن أقول إن الحمض النووي هو الناس في هونغ
كونغ نحن رائعون في ذلك
[موسيقى]